hi guys Lucy here with a gamespot news
update for you Microsoft is currently
beta testing the new xbox one system
software updates and has announced some
key features that will be seeing when
the update goes live in March among the
new additions is the long-awaited
screenshot functionality though it is
technically possible to take a
screenshot on the Xbox one the current
process is a bit complex after the March
system update however taking screenshots
will be as simple as double tackling the
Xbox Guide button and pressing Y to save
the image to local storage users with
Kinect can also say Xbox take a
screenshot meanwhile the upload studio
will act as a file manager for not just
video clips but also screenshots with
this application you can find your
chosen screenshot and select it as your
system wide wallpaper microsoft says it
also plans to use upload as a means to
publish images to social media channels
including twitter although this function
isn't available just yet there's also an
option to vary the level of transparency
for your background images and new ways
to report spam messages in terms of your
privacy settings there's a new option to
share your voice search data for
collection and analysis I think I'll
pass on that one also packaged in the
software update our new social features
such as real name requests and suggested
friends which will include people you
might know and top community
broadcasters and clip creators Microsoft
is planning to release the firmware
update at some stage in March although
it hasn't nailed a final date early
bills are currently being tested by
preview program members which functions
are you most excited about seeing do you
think there's any that Microsoft has
missed let me know in the comments
section below for all the latest on the
Xbox one make sure you stay tuned to
gamespot com
you